ce n'est que le début mais déjà assez
pour semer la consternation chez les
consommateurs il n'ya presque plus de
sarrasin sur les tablettes d'un des plus
grands supermarchés de moscou idem pour
le riz l'huile les pâtes et le sucre
il n'y a plus de sucre depuis trois
jours 17 employés d'auchan qui voulut en
réserve et deux sacs pour la maison mais
tout est vendu dit elle les gens
achètent par panique alors que le rouble
dégringole et les prix augmentent même
que certains produits sont déjà soumis
au ratio pas plus de 5 kilos par
personne explique la pancarte ce n'est
pas que pour la nourriture les
serviettes sanitaires font désormais
partie des produits essentiels qui
disparaissent à vue d'oeil séjour
les gens regardent trop la télé 7 commis
et se précipite pour vous dit les
tablettes c'est de la folie au centre
commercial atrium la nouvelle normalité
commence aussi à frapper les moscovites
une boutique sur deux n'est plus vivable
mango zara et chaque jour une autre
porte ce faire la chaîne nespresso vient
d'annoncer qu'elle n'exporte plus de
capsules de café en russie ces gens font
la file résigné et sur la célèbre place
pouchkine cmec donald qui tire
officiellement sa révérence aujourd'hui
dimitri 18 ans n'étaient pas nés quand
le mcdonald's a ouvert ses portes en
1990 mais il sera un des derniers
clients tout comme katia et pauline
et
tant de jeunes dans le monde elle venait
souvent manger après les cours entre
amis pour 150 euros ou même pas 3
dollars ce n'est pas tant les burgers
qui vont lui manquer mais ce que les
arches jaune représente
ce sentiment en deuil se rappelle la
banque bic huillet 32 ans quand il a
fait la file pour manger son tout
premier big man
c'était un symbole d'ouverture de
possibilités chose mais c'est l'occasion
disparaissent la liberté où ce en moins
de trois semaines tout change
le grand magasin adidas du centre-ville
est encore ouvert mais seulement pour
quelques jours ces jeunes qui n'ont
jamais connu la vie sans les luxe
importés de la france de l'amérique
achètent tout ce qui reste
une intention de tout revendre sur le
marché noir il faudra s'y habituer
force est de constater que son pays la
russie est devenu l'un des plus
sanctionnées du mans plus de 500
entreprises ont plié bagage le
gouvernement russe menace désormais de
saisir les biens et de nationaliser
celle qui désertent le pire cette lan a
dit qu'elle s'inquiète pour les milliers
de chômeurs mais elle est prête à tout
pour la gloire de son pays
ce que je dis à ma fille surtout c'est
de ne pas avoir honte d'être russe que
notre pays est un pays victorieux que la
russie a déjà vaincu les nazis et
qu'elle le fera de vous mais comme tant
d'autres elle est venue faire ses adieux
avec donna des mossi goodbye